The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ANNALISA L. WEIGEL: I know we've
had a very exciting morning so
far.
We've been talking about
the accounts payable case
study at Rockwell Collins.
Our next module
on A3 thinking is
going to take that setting of
the case study that we used,
and we'll launch an A3 planning
exercise from that scenario.
Before we do that, I just
want to give you a little bit
of background on A3 as a tool.
So in this module,
we expect you to be
able to do two
things at the end.
First is to recognize
that A3 is not just a tool
but really is a way
of thinking, a way
of trying to solve a problem
in a very structured way.
And secondly, we want you to
gain a little bit of practice
with using the tool of an
A3 chart as a standard tool
for implementing lean projects.
All right.
So first of all,
A3 is really a tool
for enabling our whole
PDSA or PDCA cycle.
And this is a snapshot
of one particular version
of an A3 tool up in the corner.
So as we said in the
goals for our module here,
A3 is not just a tool, but
it is also a way of thinking.
It originally evolved as a
management process from Toyota.
And it's named for the
A3 size sheet of paper,
which is roughly 11 by 17.
And it was chosen as the form
for this particular exercise,
because it is the largest
piece of paper that can fit
through a fax machine in Japan.
So you could contain
all the information
you needed on that one
page, and it was still
easily translatable
to anywhere else,
because you could put
it in a fax machine
and someone at the other
end would get it and be
able to see the whole
description of your problem
and your courses
of action presented
on that one piece of paper.
So here is in more
detail an example
of an A3 sheet that was
developed at Toyota.
You can see on
your tables we have
some starts of an A3 sheet
for the Rockwell Collins case
study.
And they're also
blown up here very
largely on the butcher paper
that's around the room.
And they're broken down
into several sections.
And I just want to spend
the next couple of slides
walking you through the
basic purpose of an A3
and the different
sections of it.
And I really have to
thank Susan for giving us
this great introduction to
A3 as a tool in her talk
that happened earlier.
And she showed you
some excellent examples
of what these actually look
like when they're created.
So first, at the top you
want to start with a title.
What is it that
you're talking about?
What is the focus of your
problem investigation?
Then there's some
background on why
you're talking about it and
the particular business context
for the problem
you're examining.
Then more detail on
the current situation.
And you saw in
Susan's representation
some great pictures
and diagrams.
Pictures can be worth
a thousand words.
They're very helpful
in communicating that.
Sometimes a picture and some
couple of phrases of text
may be all that you need.
Then there's some
analysis usually done,
trying to get at,
really, what's the root
cause of the problem
you're seeing,
requirements, constraints,
or alternatives
that have to be considered.
And then lastly down here,
although it's sliding off
the page, is the goal.
So what's the specific
change that you
want to accomplish now?
So this is called the
left-hand side of the A3.
And then over here on
the right-hand side
starts up with your
recommendations.
So what's your proposed
countermeasures
to remedy the root causes that
you've identified over here
and get to your goal?
Then a plan for how
you're going to implement
those recommendations, and
who's going to do what and when,
and then some follow-up.
So how will you know if
the actions that you're
planning really have the impact
that you expected they do?
And this not only lets you know
that your actions have been
successful, but it also
confirms that your understanding
of the problem was right.
Because of what you thought
was going to happen happened,
that's a good
reinforcement for it.
All right.
So we just want to stress again
that the thought process used
in A3 thinking-- thinking
about the context,
analyzing the problem,
figuring out root causes,
setting a goal, thinking about
your steps to then remedy it--
it really is a thought
process, it's not just a tool.
And sometimes you hear
people talking about A3,
and sometimes it feels like
they get lost in the tool
and they've somewhat
forgotten about the process.
Another important
attribute of this,
it really is collaborative.
Everybody should get
around an A3 sheet.
It's small enough so you
can all see what's going on,
and it lets people who are
all part of the solutions
get together to figure out
how to solve the problem.
It promotes very logical
and objective thinking.
We stress having
data on your A3 sheet
in your description of the
situation and in the analysis.
It lets you think about
the results and the process
that you might take to try to
meet some of your objectives.
It forces you to be synthetic
about the problem you're
thinking about, because you only
have one A3 page to write it
on.
So you've got to be able to
understand your problem well
enough, distill it well
enough, that you can convey it
in a nice, contained space.
It forces alignment between
the context of the situation,
the problems you're seeing,
the root causes of those,
the goals that you
want to achieve,
and the actions
that you're going
to take to make that happen.
Those all have to be aligned.
And you can see that
in the A3 sheet.
Then as a result, you have
some coherence, both within
and consistency across all
these elements in your A3 sheet.
And it really makes sure that
you take a systems perspective
on the problem to get
out of those silos.
So just a little
bit more information
about each section of the A3.
So we'll start with what's
typically on the left-hand
side--
the background, the current
situation, analysis, and goals.
Diagrams are very
useful and efficient
for communicating in
small spaces like that.
And on Susan's examples of
A3, you saw a lot of diagrams.
Value stream maps were shown up
in the current situation, which
showed the items of interest,
the process flow between them.
It showed you some data on
that, and then identified
those cloudbursts of areas
where there were problems.
So some useful questions to ask
as you start to put together
the left side of the sheet.
Are the activities clearly
specified with regards
to the content, in order,
and intended outcomes
as you work through the current
situation analysis and goals?
And are the connections
between all the entities
that are involved in
your A3 problem very
clear and explicit?
So now, moving over to the
right-hand side of the A3
sheet--
thinking about
recommendations and plans.
When you're thinking
about recommendations,
you really want to make
sure that they're directly
addressing the root cause.
So there has to be
consistency between that part
of your A3 sheet and
where you describe
the root causes taking place.
And they really should help
you evolve your process
from the current state
towards something
that you see as an ideal
state by eliminating
some of the root causes.
And then in the
plan section, that's
where you're going to
define the steps to correct
each of the root causes--
so, again, traceability and
connectivity, back to that.
And in the process
of doing so, you
have to identify who exactly is
responsible for what, and when,
and exactly what it is
that they're going to do.
And then the last
part of the A3 sheet
is really the continuous
improvement part of it.
This is your
follow-up activities.
So how do you know that what
you wanted to happen, happened?
And make sure that when you're
thinking about what you're
going to look at in
the follow-up section,
that links back to your
original goals for this,
and the criteria and metrics
that you set up for that.
So we have an example
here in the module.
Susan has already teed up
a lot of great examples.
And you're going to be going
through one in your exercise.
So I don't think I
want to spend much time
on this particular example.
This happens to be from Acme
stamping steering bracket value
stream improvement exercise.
And just to show you the breadth
of situations across which
A3 thinking can apply,
you see one here
for manufacturing process.
We saw lots for health
care from Susan.
And now we're going to go
and do one in the office area
and accounts payable.
So really, there's no limit
to the context in which you
can apply A3 thinking,
because it's really
all about structured
problem solving.
What I will note before
leaving this example
is the prevalence of the
visual types of information.
So they have their current
state map, a future state
map on here, a Gantt
chart that they
have used to describe
their plan, which
are all the deliverables
that have to happen,
and who is going to do them,
who's responsible for them,
and when.
So you can see how these
visual representations
pack a lot of information
into a nice, tight space.
Further examples-- we
may have come across this
in our New Balance video.
I can't recall exactly.
But when you go into the
New Balance plant for sure,
you see these--
they're actually
whiteboard-sized,
so a little bit large.
So you can actually have people
with markers writing on them.
This is an A3 chart.
And it's up around
the factory floor.
So that's an incredibly powerful
boundary-spanning object.
And all the workers
in a cell can
get together around
their A3 board
and strategize about
problem solving.
And here's an
example where they've
written up in this section
their root cause analysis.
And they chose to do a
five whys to get down
to their root cause.
And it's just wonderful to
see this being used right
on the factory floor.
And it's quite
powerful to have that
there right in
front of the station
where everybody is
doing their work.
So it's not kept by somebody
else in a desk drawer
somewhere.
It's just up front and visual.
All right.
So now let's move into our
exercise for this module, which
is taking the Rockwell Collins
accounts payable case study.
And we're going to use that
to create an A3 sheet on what
we should do to try to
solve some of the problems
that Rockwell is encountering.
So on your table, you'll each
have a small size of these
so you can refer to it.
And then each of the
groups has a larger version
up on the easel charts.
So each of the tables is going
to be working with a group.
And you're going to
develop an A3 plan which
responds to question 8
in the case study, which
is, "Suppose you are
the RPI team leader
and have to report
back to Joanie.
What will you recommend?"
So we'd like you to spend
about 20 minutes preparing
with your team at
the table an A3 plan.
All right.
And we've given you
the template that you
can use to fill that out.
So first, we have to remember
what the constraints are.
I'll detail those
in the next slide.
You should also consider what
Rockwell Collins groups should
participate in this rapid
process improvement team.
So make sure you think
about all stakeholders.
Then you'll want to verify
that the information we've
provided to you on
those sheets is correct.
Complete the
additional information
blocks that are in the template.
And you can use some of the
Post-It notes on the large A3
to draft the different
elements that you want.
And then you can record
your final recommendations
on the large A3 sheet.
And at the end of
the class, we'll
have some table tours where
you can walk around and see
what your different
colleague teams have
produced for their plans.
And then we'll have a discussion
and compare and contrast
some of the strategies that you
thought about in this context.
So just very briefly, the
management constraints
as we pulled from the
case study are these.
So remember, your main objective
is to reduce cycle time,
going for a goal of
invoice resolution in less
than 10 days.
But shorter than
that is even better.
Management wants to establish
a training program for everyone
that's affected by the change.
They'd like to formalize
communication requirements
for invoice payments
with suppliers.
Changes have to be accomplished
within the current system.
So there's no purchasing new
IT systems to actually solve
the problem.
And also, to use already
available in-house software
or IT technology.
Those sort of go hand in hand.
Any action items that might
be addressed in your A3 plan
have to be completed
within 30 days.
And there can't be
any additional staff.
So an outcome of
your A3 can't be,
"let's hire five new people."
That wouldn't be acceptable.
All right.
So I'm going to leave the
management constraints
up here on the projector
so you can see them
as you're working through your
problem solving activities.
And we'll ask each
table to get started.
We'll have the instructors
in the class walking around
to answer questions and help
you through the process.
So take about 20--
yeah, 20 minutes.
So I'll give you a 3-minute
warning when we get
to the end of that time period.
PROFESSOR: Could
someone suggest what
might be one of
the things you're
going to have to do to
implement these recommendations?
Just one thing.
AUDIENCE: Cross-training.
PROFESSOR: Cross-training, OK.
Let's just take
cross-training, OK?
So you're going to have
some kind of recommendation
on training.
How's that going to--
who's going to do that?
When's it going to get done
in the sequence of things?
I find a useful way
to think about this
is that maybe think
of each of you
as one of the stakeholders
in the organization.
Maybe you're the mailroom
guy, and Celeste, maybe you're
the accounts payable person.
And think about
what would be done
in your area to implement this.
Maybe you're a vendor.
So you've got to
change your mind now.
Don't go back and redo
the whole problem.
We spent all morning doing that.
Think about, we've
got to implement it.
And you've got to
come back to Joanie.
And [INAUDIBLE]?
ANNALISA L. WEIGEL: Yes.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So focus on this task.
AUDIENCE: This is
change billing address.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
And the next thing we
need to do is we need to--
AUDIENCE: Who does that?
Who does that?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Who does it?
AUDIENCE: Who changes
the billing address?
AUDIENCE: Purchasing.
Because [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Purchasing, yep.
AUDIENCE: Simply from
the sheer magnitude,
I would say to get the five
Xs on the end of the invoices
on the outside of
the company would
reduce a massive amount of
letters coming in, number one.
And while that's
being done, it allows
us to train some of the people
inside the company to implement
the next few steps.
AUDIENCE: So use local
companies for faster turnaround.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: They just do--
they just throw out the Xs.
We got that.
AUDIENCE: The call center
needs to be trained.
AUDIENCE: In what?
AUDIENCE: How to use--
AUDIENCE: IT has to be aware--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: IT needs to-- yeah.
ANNALISA L. WEIGEL: All right.
So what we'd like
to do at this point,
recognizing that not
all the implementation
plans are finished
and that's OK,
is we'd like to go around
the room around the tables
and have you share with us where
you are in your implementation
plan and what you've
come up with so far.
Try to limit your summary
for us to 60 seconds or less.
I'm going to ask to start
with the table in the front,
and we'll go around the room.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So thinking about the
three different decisions,
we have purchasing, the
mailroom, and accounts payable.
So the one who will be
doing the training, probably
the senior management, talk to
the main leaders in each group.
And we want to train
at the same time,
because [INAUDIBLE] scheduling
issues have the purchasing
group trainers
have to add the Xs.
But now we're going to train
them to recognize the Xs.
And then they have to be able to
train them in document imaging.
And then after the simpler
steps, and then in the future,
create a call center
within the mailroom
to train the staff [INAUDIBLE].
ANNALISA L. WEIGEL:
Very good, thank you.
So let's go around
to the next group.
And you can tell us
what you thought about.
AUDIENCE: We focused on the
implementation of the labeling
of--
the first one we had five
Xs to the [INAUDIBLE]
of our invoices.
And the way we're
going to do this,
we're going to have
a small meeting where
we have a representative
from the mailroom,
and a representative
from purchasing,
as well as one of us who
came up with all these ideas,
sit down together and
decide what the format needs
to be of this addition.
It could be that some suppliers'
names or some, whatever
in the address block,
would be too big,
and you would never actually
see the Xs because they
would move off--
the little window
in the envelopes.
So we just have to decide what
exactly the format, the best
lettering would be to add on.
Five Xs may not be the best.
Once we know what we want
to put on, we pick one
of our medium-sized suppliers--
we picked Ben & Jerry's
for obvious reasons--
and set up a meeting with them.
Again, we would have
a purchasing rep,
we'd have the mailroom
rep there, but also
the supplier rep to hopefully
bring the ice cream.
And then we would talk to--
just talk them through
the whole process
and just make them aware
of the whole situation.
They don't really
have to do anything
if we have purchasing
implement the whole solution.
But they need to be aware
[INAUDIBLE] are also
the random letters
on the orders.
Actually, I never
mentioned this.
We were thinking about
purchasing when the order gets
sent initially, that
purchasing actually,
when they type in the order,
that they would add the tag as
opposed to the supplier.
They would add the tag and
then the supplier would just
see the letters, wouldn't
have to add them.
And then just watch
how well it goes.
ANNALISA L. WEIGEL: OK.
All right.
Let's go around
to the next table.
AUDIENCE: So we tried to
introduce a vendor pilot for--
using a vendor pilot
for our suppliers,
so add a XXX and a PFR.
We started with a pilot model,
maybe one or two suppliers,
and then scale up if,
depending on the success,
or introduce some little
modifications as need be,
before we expand for the PFR.
And then much of our--
we talked about the IT
work on the scanners.
And then we'd also have to train
staff on the document imaging,
so be able to use the scanners.
And then we also
talked about training.
But the Lotus Notes, we realized
that that was the point where
when one staff member is away,
others cannot do her function,
his/her function,
take her place.
So we thought of
training our analysts
to be able to use the Lotus
Notes so that even when
one person is away,
other people can
fill in the space and work--
could go on that way.
So that's what we came up with.
ANNALISA L. WEIGEL: Great.
Thank you.
So all very three
different ideas.
This is great.
Go ahead, next table.
AUDIENCE: We spent
most of the time
talking about the process
of scanning documents
into the system, and
who would be doing it.
We talked about whether
we could have a rotating
analyst, in which case--
because they would
have knowledge
of what the different needs are,
or whether we would do someone
from purchasing or
from [INAUDIBLE],,
and probably having
a meeting to talk
about that within the group
would be the best way.
And then when you would have to
train people to use the Lotus
Notes, and also
doing the scanner,
and the outcome would be that
all the documents are scanned,
and you would have some
cross-training ability
so that, kind of as
mentioned previously,
if one person's out, you still
would have the work done.
ANNALISA L. WEIGEL: OK.
Last table.
AUDIENCE: We talked a
lot about the process
of putting the tags
onto the addresses
and used a similar idea to
that table of the pilot.
We wanted to start
with like one person
from purchasing, and training
them and adding to the tags.
And [INAUDIBLE] local company or
a couple of local companies to
add it to, just so
that we could be sure
that we actually got the
invoices before the end
of our 30-day period.
And then also, train
all the mailroom
on that first day
about what to expect,
because they'd start seeing
those Xs [INAUDIBLE] we
can't guarantee that one versus
another person would see them.
And then we also talked a bit
about what the analysts had
to do regarding
what exactly they
need to know to no
longer check for PFRs,
because that's going
to be a bit tough--
it's not very clear-cut time
when those will stop coming in.
Also, we discussed how
to find the new images
after the document is scanned,
instead of on the microfilm.
So that was the [INAUDIBLE].
Anything else I'm missing?
ANNALISA L. WEIGEL: OK.
Excellent.
Well, these are all very good
starts to the implementation
plan.
It's fascinating to
see the different ways
that your groups approached them
and which aspects you thought
you wanted to start on, as well
as level of details that some
of your groups thought about.
A lot of great transition
issues are raised
and how you implement
lean kinds of new programs
that you're thinking about.
So this group talked
about training.
A number of you
talked about training,
the importance of that.
And if you don't
provide training,
efforts can fail
before you even begin.
And this group talked
about some staged rollout,
as did other groups.
So let's do pilots--
test a little bit,
see if it works.
And then if it
does work, then we
can deploy it on a larger
scale, and if it doesn't we
will find that and test a little
bit more before we get success
and then go out.
Also an excellent attribute
of trying to implement
a big change like that.
What really happened
in Rockwell Collins?
Are you curious?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ANNALISA L. WEIGEL: Right.
OK.
So they implemented
the recommendations.
And it didn't work.
They weren't seeing any change
in their performance metrics.
What do you think was happening?
Any guesses?
I don't expect you to know.
I don't expect you to
have a right guess, but.
AUDIENCE: Too much
change at once?
ANNALISA L. WEIGEL:
Too much change?
Yeah, what else?
AUDIENCE: They just didn't
understand what was going on.
ANNALISA L. WEIGEL:
They didn't know--
that's pretty much accurate.
So what happened was
the analyst said,
oh, you've got a new system?
Well, I don't like
this new system.
I don't know this new system.
I'm not going to
follow this new system.
And they started calling all
their contacts and saying,
look, you know, they've
implemented this new system,
but forget about it.
If you have a problem, just
give me a call directly.
And they just totally
subverted all the systems
that were put in place, largely
because they didn't understand
that the document
imaging and Lotus Notes
was going to be useful for them.
So Rockwell said, all right.
You know what, we'll just--
we'll back away from this,
and we'll do this sort of in
a staged deployment method.
So they just got the
analysts trained up
and comfortable on the document
imaging to see that was useful.
And then when that
happened, then they
went to their pooled
queue calling center
and then initiated that.
So it took a little while,
but they eventually got it.
But the implementation
was challenging because
of these issues that very
perceptively were raised
just about, human nature
and organizational natures
when we come into
big change problems.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So how does the
culture of organization
play a role in implementation
of recommendations?
ANNALISA L. WEIGEL: It
plays a huge role, right?
I mean, we've kind
of been alluding
to this over the course
the last couple of days.
And some cultures and
the way that they operate
are going to be more
amenable to change--
that may be part of their
culture-- and accepting of it.
And others are not going
to accept change so much.
And you have to really
recognize which one you're in so
that you can approach
any kind of change effort
in a way that's going to make
sense to the organization
that you're in and be
productive as a result.
But it's a really
big topic, and longer
than we have time to address
in a quick question here.
But we can talk about
it during the break.